sortie de couple pour Tom et Sylvie en
ce premier dimanche de mai ensemble ils
discutent regarde sentent et choisissent
ce qu'ils vont planter dans leur potager
qu'est-ce que tu as planté c'est plus
c'est plus naturel pour rejouer dans la
terre à plus d'un avantage même si
l'activité surtout liée à leurs papiers
gustatif c'est pas pour le prix c'est
plus pour le goût c'est dans le meilleur
goût
de travailler
d'ailleurs ils sont nombreux à déjà
déambulé dans cette pépinière de
Longueuil avant la cohue de la langue
fin de semaine de mai période conseillée
par les horticulteurs pour démarrer son
potager sans risque de gel au sol dans
les deux dernières années la popularité
des plantes légumes a augmenté selon un
des propriétaires qui entrevoit une
autre bonne saison de vente pour 2023
j'ai vendu quasiment le double de la
quantité de légumes que je vais en
normalement l'année passée selon lui
c'est encore possible de faire des
économies en produisant ses propres
légumes une boîte de laitue qui se vend
aux alentours de 6 dollars on a 9 plan
de l'étude dedans enfin que on est rendu
une pièce
une pièce éclate pour la lecture
France
aujourd'hui il cherche des fines herbes
des piments phares et des plantes de
tomates pour leur balcon auparavant
c'est un grand jardin qu'ils
aménageaient sans trop d'impact sur le
portefeuille moi j'avais un énorme
jardin c'était comme deux rangées comme
ici avant j'avais la maison puis on a
acheté ça coûte presque rien puis
maintenant faut surveiller les prix et
pour ceux qui voudraient commencer le
jardinage cette année sans savoir par où
commencer l'expert tient à vous rassurer
peu importe ce que vous allez choisir
vous embellirez au moins votre
environnement ici Carla Oliveira
Radio-Canada Longueuil